Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and Disney finally
revealed the title for Star Wars 7 as The
Force Awakens. I have all kinds of reactions
to the news but there are also reports that
they’ve finished the first teaser trailer
and will be posting it before the end of the
So what I’m going to do is breakdown why
I think they chose that title in particular
and what it says about the movie itself and
the potential release dates for that trailer.
Hello any new people, if you’re finding
me for the first time I do weekly Star Wars
videos. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And please leave me all your requests.
Starting off with the most obvious things
about the title. One, it’s about the Force
not just Jedi or Sith. Some of you might remember
the EU novel The unifying force. I don’t
think that’s relevant to the title but it
just does a good job of describing the good
and evil schools of practice.
Second, they dropped the “Episode” from
the title. It’s just Star Wars The Force
Awakens, it’s not Episode 7 The Force Awakens.
There are a couple of reasons for that, I
think it’s great. The only reason we started
using them was to distinguish between the
Prequels and the Original Trilogy. When all
those movies were originally released they
were always Empire Strikes Back or Attack
of the Clones.
Lucasfilm and Disney are trying to get to
the point where they can release at least
one new Star Wars film every year. I think
eventually that will turn into two films.
Going back to Episode 7: What does The Force
Awakens title say about the action of the
film?
We’ll probably be seeing the beginning of
a new Jedi and Sith Order. The force will
awaken inside some of the new characters.
I know a lot of you have already pointed out
that technically the force is already awake.
Luke Skywalker is filling in as the Obi Wan
Kenobi figure in the movie and we know there
will be some form of Dark Jedi. So just like
with the Star Trek reboot, Star Wars is going
to introduce the Force in a new way to a new
cast of characters.
Just to clarify though, it’s not a Star
Trek scenario. Episode 7 isn’t a reboot.
I’m just referring to the passing of the
torch from the original Star Trek movies to
the new cast with Chris Pine. And no, I don’t
think that all the original cast will die
before Episode 8 or 9.
There have been a lot of rumors and yes, when
they were making the original trilogy, Harrison
Ford lobbied George Lucas to kill off Han
Solo. I wouldn’t worry about that too much.
I just feel like based on the kinds of movies
JJ Abrams makes, what we’ll see is a transition.
As the movies progress, the story will focus
less and less on the original cast.
Which means we need new Jedi Heroes and New
Sith Villains. Thus the Awakens title.
There’s also the chance that they could
go in a 2001 Space Odyssey route and do a
Star Child type thing where the Force itself
plays a role as a really abstract living organism.
So what about the first Trailer. That’s
really what we’re all waiting for. Right
now we know that John Williams is writing
new original music just for the trailer. Because
of his, shall we say, maturity, he can’t
fly to London on a dime. London is where the
film was shot. They just finished shooting
with the actors.
Because of that, he’s scheduled to actually
record the music for the trailer next week.
Meaning, once he’s done, they can add the
music to the trailer and release it anytime
they want.
In the past the first star wars trailers dropped
in November and December, but all those movies
were released in April and May. Because Episode
7 is a december release it’s rumored that
they’ll go ahead and release the first teaser
a year out instead of 7 months like in the
past.
Because Disney’s only big movie in december
is Into the Woods and that’s Christmas Day.
They could attach the teaser to that.
I think it’s possible they could go the
Marvel route and do their own big separate
press event where they unveil it. Either way,
plan on a very short teaser between December
16th and the 23rd. Those are just Tuesday’s
and new trailers typically come on Tuesdays.
I think the first full trailer will be attached
to Avengers 2.
Just to clarify, I think the teaser will be
really short, whatever it is they’re releasing
at the end of the year. Like less than a minute
of footage. It will probably just be music
with maybe a Luke Skywalker voice over, like
the Ben Kenobi speech from Episode 4. The
speech he first gives luke about what the
force is and what it represents.
That just feels like the best possible thing
they could do if they’re not going to have
scenes from the movie in it.
The first official trailer will be about 2
and a half minutes, it will have dialogue,
it will have actual scenes from the movie.
But we’ll have to wait to Avengers 2 to
see that probably.
Let me know what you think, Regardless of
when it drops what do you think is
going to be in that
first teaser trailer.
Is it going to
be just voice over or do
you
think we’ll see actual footage
from
the movie.
JJ Abrams has really unusual creative ways
of revealing information about his movies.
Like with the cryptic Star Wars pictures addressing
all the leaks. I have no doubt that he’ll
do something similar when they get ready to
post footage.
Of all the things I’m looking forward to
it’s actually the prospect of all the different
directors working on
the films.
First off, my favorite is Empire Strikes Back,
very common choice. It’s one of the few
films NOT directed by George Lucas.
For all these new films. Rian Johnson is actually
directing the second one. So right away everyone
go watch Brick and Looper again. And all the
spinoff movies will have different directors.
They’re picking lesser non-mega directors
like Spielberg and JJ Abrams for future films
because these newer people have interesting
new takes on the characters and the universe.
That’s something to get excited about. A
Star Wars movie that doesn’t look like any
Star Wars movie you’ve ever seen before
without completely throwing away the things
that made you fall in love with it in the
first place.
Just in case you didn’t know Episode 7 is
being released December 18th.
I already do weekly star wars videos, but
if there’s anthing special about the movies
you guys want to talk about please leave me
requests for videos and be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
Right now I usually post my Rebels videos
on Tuesdays, so that’s kind of like my Star
Wars Day.
You can click here to catch up and click here
to learn more about the villains in episode
7.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you guys tonight!